let's talk about this story here from
The Daily Mail conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones must still pay 1 billion in
Damages to sanduk families and can't
hide behind his bankruptcy protection
judge
rules this is crazy they are saying that
bankruptcy is not enough so the general
idea of the bank of a bankruptcy is hey
we need to prioritize what we're paying
back to keep the company operating if
they begin to seize his assets Infowars
will cease to exist that was always the
point I'm not surprised this is
happening it's going to get a lot worse
in 2024 they're going to start going
after
everybody
yeah there's kind of part of it with the
whole YouTube thing it's going to start
happen yeah it's all going to start
happening this is different from you
know Fox what the thing about Fox News
and the and the strike I think this is
just something that needs to be uh the
precedent has not been set on a new
technology and a change in how the
public operates right so this is one of
the first elections where you have
ubiquity live streams with prominent
personalities who dominate prime time so
of course the argument from fox is like
hey what do you think you're doing and
it's like welcome to the new world of
public participation this technology
exists people have always played the
debates and argued and debated them and
fact checked them to the public now it's
happening in digital world right if Fox
News has their way it reverses the
internet I you know hey maybe then
there's no living the potne the bugs
because you can't have digital broadcast
and digital public debate they'd get rid
of it this is different Alex Jones has
opinions 10 years ago he had very bad
ones he's got a pay a billion dollars
okay fine he lost they had a some right
judgment against him he files for
bankruptcy this will destroy the company
it'll get all my employees fired and the
judge says so what this is law fair this
is they are trying to destroy Alex Jones
and you know you had talked earlier like
said earlier about like defamation
lawsuits now they have to to be said in
Malice and I truly don't believe he said
those things in Malice back then you
know what I'm saying I think he truly
believed them back then and just clarify
actual malice means you intentionally
lied you knew what you were saying was
false yeah so you say something
intentionally knowing it was false so it
absolutely is cuz like a lot of us like
we there's a lot of like misinformation
there's a lot of stuff out there like we
say things we see things and we make you
know a statement believing it at the
time he didn't say that in Malice like
he truly believed what he was saying at
the time and now they're still coming
after him 10 years later even though and
he never even said anything like Alex
Jones never said anything that stated oh
yeah I knew it wasn't true and I said it
anyway so it really is just a continued
weaponization of the justice system to
shut down all descent to shut down
digital media cuz they're coming for you
next cuz cable television is dying and
digital is the future and anybody who
has a name for themselves or makes some
really good points or actually does some
damage on culture taking back the the
culture they're going to try and come
for you so that's just what they do so
you have to you know and
honestly apologizing to they come after
you when you start apologizing they
smell blood you never apologize never
they smell blood and they will take you
all the way down struggle session thing
don't apologize in a struggle session
yep just sit there and take it and leave
that's true that's it why did they say
that he can't file for bankruptcy and
protect himself that way I mean I assume
the reason is arbitrary quote the
families are pleased with the court
ruling that Jones's malicious conduct
will find no Safe Harbor in the
bankruptcy court said Christopher M A
Connecticut lawyer as a result Jones
will continue to be accountable for his
actions on his site yada yada I don't
know that seems absurd also where is he
supposed to get a billion dollars he
only has 14 million like saying we know
you don't have it but that's not good
enough right is he supposed to get it if
they shut down his channel that's the
only way he makes money because it's not
what it's about yeah exactly so they
just want to
Scuttle him this is I think this proves
it if it was really about recovering
damages they'd say bankruptcy must
protect Alex Jones and then we will
garnish whatever wages and profit he
would get off his show right but if
they're saying no bankruptcy protection
then infowar ceases to exist and that's
it end of story no money for anybody
yeah it's kind of like an by any means
possible kind of thing is what I'm
saying no matter what you whatever they
can do I don't know if it says what is
explanation for why bankruptcy doesn't
apply
uh at least here it just says the judge
said it so it is I don't I don't know
what the argument is yeah when was this
ruled was this today today really this
just happened today I knew that they
like of like initially were suing him
for the entire like it was like the same
amount as the military or something like
like the defense budg budget of the
United States something ridiculous and
it was you know I mean they're just
trying to take him down you know I hope
Alex stays strong we we're with you man
like this is not good um and they're
just like it's not even legal it's not
legal what they're doing and I hope he
appeals it I know that different states
have different um you know standards on
how much you can sue a person for so
like in the state of Connecticut like
even though it was in Connecticut in
some places like they couldn't sue him
for more than a certain amount legally
so I don't know if this still applies to
that or if that just overrules all of
that I have to read
it even CNN doesn't doesn't give the the
reasoning behind why he's not protected
from like bankruptcy no do this doesn't
make
sense it just says the judge said it the
familyes filed the motion because they
thought he wouldn't pay and then it goes
on to explain the the past lawsuit I
love the logic behind that we thought we
wouldn't pay us so we just charged you
bunch more money millions and millions
more dollars well no they're saying we
thought he wouldn't pay because of the
bankrupcy so he had we want the judge to
say he can't use bankruptcy the judge
said okay oh wow but but it doesn't
explain what the Jud how the what the
judge is uh uh why yeah exactly why is
this one bypassing bankruptcy I still
don't think the family get a single
penny and it's because if Jones goes if
infow goes out infow Wars is out of
business there's no money right yeah
exactly most of the most of the debt
that cannot be discharged in bankruptcy
is child support alimony unpaid taxes
and student loan debt most other things
according to Investopedia can be
alleviated through
bankruptcy h yeah so I wonder what makes
this special yeah you know like what the
what the law is there and he fired filed
chapter 11 is that what he did or was it
yeah chapter 11 chapter
11 he says uh those uh okay so Lopez
ruled the protections do not apply over
findings of willful and malicious
conduct oh that's another one here it is
it says depths for debts for willful and
malicious injury to another person or
property willful and malicious here
means deliberate and without just cause
and that's um so that's one too deaths
for death or personal injury it was a
default ruling caused by the D yeah that
doesn't seem there was no trial over
this yeah there was only there was only
a settlement hearing Jones never
actually got to argue any of his case
yep that does not seem uh that doesn't
seem how did we get to that point though
I mean look people keep saying oh you
know Civil War is a stupid thing to say
and it's like dude it's not just that
Trump has been indicted on like 91 or 94
counts it's not just that they've
arrested his lawyers it's not just that
a couple of his lawyers have just been
sentenced to five and six years of
probation for being his lawyers it's not
just that they're going after Alex Jones
in what is clearly going to destroy a
media Ellet uh and that he got no trial
for it it's not just that Donald Trump
was found in a summary judgment to have
committed fraud without a trial in New
York it's not just that a judge said
Donald Trump properties are worth a
fraction of what they're actually worth
even to the protest of of Finance
experts and real estate experts it is
not just that they have been targeting
Trump supporters J Sixers solitary
confinement it's not just that far
leftists have received no penalty for
The Hundreds who stormed the capital
recently they light light slap on the
wrist it's not just that Ricky vaugh
Douglas Mackey gets seven seven months
seven months and a Democrat who did the
same thing gets nothing should the list
go on should the list go on it goes on
endlessly no I'm just saying there is so
much evidence that the machine is trying
to crush and destroy you for political
reasons to argue that we are not
entering one of the most dangerous times
in this country's history is ludicrous
and you'd have to
forget every every yesterday to believe
we are not headed towards something
truly dark now I kind of don't think
we're losing to be completely honest
like I said there's a lot of reasons to
think that we are winning but the
desperation is becoming palpable and I
don't know to what degree this goes it
may just be Trump wins and then oh there
we go but you guys watch the culture War
episode we did this morning I think it's
Episode 34 it may be with Dr Robert
Epstein as he breaks down the machine of
Google Facebook big Tech and how they
are controlling what you think and they
know everything about what you're doing
we've talked about it Facebook can
predict if you're going to quit your job
Facebook can predict if you're going to
go have a bite to eat Facebook know what
restaurant you're going to before you
even know because the the the algorithms
the AI it knows all of the
characteristics about you and then it
can formulate these probabilities and
know exactly what you're going to do
that's why when you'll be you could be
thinking something and then you see an
ad for it and you didn't say it out loud
and you didn't say anything to anybody
you're just thinking it this is this
freaky I hate when that happens happens
and it's freaky people think that the
reason an ad will appear on Instagram
like you're talking with your buddy and
you're like you know I I I kind of think
I need a TV and then an ad appears like
get a new TV you're like yo it's spying
on me it's not no predictive algorithms
know more about you than you know about
yourself now don't get me wrong they're
spying on you for sure and um if you
have voice activation on your phone your
phone is recording everything you say
always right because in order to
activate it has to be listening to you
right and if you want your phone to
activate whenever you say your pass
phrase then it has to be listening all
the time waiting for that passphrase how
does voice activation work voice works
by taking your voice sending it off to a
private company Translating that audio
file into a text file sending it back to
your device and then inputting that as
as a command which means everything you
say several famous stories where uh uh
there was a murder and an Amazon device
recorded the entire murder and they were
like we have the recording and people
are like how in order to activate the
Amazon device it must be always
recording yeah otherwise how does it
know when you say those words
it's like arguing that you know you're
you you plug your ears and put on
headphones so no one so you can't hear
anything but as soon as someone says
your name you'll take them off well how
you going to hear them say your name if
you're wearing ear ear muffs that's the
same thing with these these Amazon
Google devices they are listening 247
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at
timcast.net censored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time